Nogales straddles the border between the
United States and Mexico it's a town
divided in half it's through here that
cartel gangs oversee the illegal
smuggling of people to the United States
the growing number of whom come from all
over the world not just Latin America
the border fence stretches out four
miles on either side and right through
the center of Nogales families spit by
the fence often meet at weekends to say
hello physically they're inches apart in
reality they could be split forever the
ever-present sound of the railway with
trains passing across the border line is
a reminder that legitimate traffic isn't
hampered by the fence with the right
contacts illegal traffic isn't either
we're traveling to a secret location to
meet the people who make the crossing
possible a part of the Sinaloa cartel a
vast powerful crime organization their
traffic people these days but their
business was founded on drugs they take
both businesses very seriously you have
an armed guard always obviously yeah the
store with the drawers they call
marijuana there's a stop if you want to
see you certainly what I got the success
of the people smuggling operation is
founded on there now well documented but
nonetheless staggering efficiency of the
drug cartels to move their product can
be drugs of course but it can be people
as well so the final destination so this
is Mexico yes it is dangerous the gang
members never stopped checking for
suspicious movement outside their
so-called warehouse a flat to you and me
the business depends on the link between
the various gangs over vast distances to
coordinate the movement of the cargo
they say that the they pay there and
then they passed from one person to
another person to another person when
they come all the way through from South
America from Central America a you part
of that I mean you know they're coming
yeah do you know these people are coming
even from a long time before yes because
you know like they say you live in
Guatemala right you send me people to
here so you call me let me know so no I
sent two guys three four five guys okay
the people who went across to Mexico and
Chula Vista know when I bestow a Chiapas
so this is different life you know the
they call me you know that the device
already so and then to when gate to
Mexico and the different guy that comes
you know is the people in Mexico so when
I send the true Novalis
later okay really well yeah this gang
has been able to move people and drugs
across the border for years it's a
sophisticated business throw watch
positions cartels Scouts monitor the
movement of US border patrols and can
simply direct drug mules and people
smugglers when the way is clear
we found them they didn't like it and
the message clear go away the two
thousand mile long border is for large
sections little more than a wire fence
with a few bits of old railway line
welded together it might stop cattle but
not much else
the cartel and crime gangs across Latin
America and Beyond are focused on
getting people and drugs to the United
States it's a battle and by and large
the smugglers are winning Sturm Zee Sky
News on the Mexico United States border